what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down the dark aftermath of the
tragic battle between the world's
strongest hero and all for one slash
shigaraki a battle that changed
everything in this final act of the mha
story all for one is still on the loose
but he has been weakened the ultimate
fate of new order one of the strongest
quirks in the history of mha is still a
mystery and deku bakugo and the rest of
class 1a are back in the story and
preparing for a battle to the death
against the villains let's get into it
you guys know the drill if you enjoy our
mha videos and you want to see more in
the future just leave a quick like and
comment it only takes a second but it
helps with the youtube algorithm and of
course if you're new to the channel or
you watch our videos but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a quick favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications it might seem like a small
thing to you but it's actually a huge
deal in terms of supporting this channel
finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned okay so first up as you guys
will recall at the end of the previous
chapter we saw what looked like that
flying nomu that shigaraki had used
earlier the image was very small and
from a distance so i just assumed that
it was the nomu and i was surprised by
this because this freaking nomu should
have been super dead by now it was hit
by lasers by missiles and then it's
self-destructed well it turns out that
nomu really is dead and what we saw
flying in the distance were just the
nomu's wings right before commanding the
nomu to self-destruct all for one in
chicago's body removed the nomu's flying
quirk so essentially the nomu's wings i
guess detached from the nomu and attach
themselves to shigaraki so what we saw
at the end of the previous chapter was
shigaraki using the wings of that no
mood to fly and he is currently
attempting to use the unique properties
of these wings to shake off the pilots
who are still pursuing him but even
though the villain was able to pull off
this beat and switch move with the wings
his body is still breaking apart from
the inside as new order continues to
absolutely annihilate the other quirk
factors he has to find a way to transfer
new order to someone else as soon as
possible while at the same time trying
to avoid being completely destroyed by
those jets and the pilots of those jets
are absolutely determined to make the
villain pay for what happened to stars
and stripes so this is a very dangerous
situation for all for one slash shigeru
his body is being destroyed from the
inside while he's also trying to dodge
attacks from multiple jets on the
outside one wrong move and his entire
body could break apart for good and it's
game over for the villains as noted in
the previous chapter all for one slash
shigaraki sees new order as the ghost of
all might and he is furious that no
matter where he goes he just can't seem
to escape all might's shadow america
chan was inspired to become a hero by
all might's actions and she worked her
whole life to live up to the high
standards that all might had set so as
far as the villain is concerned the new
order quirk factor that is currently
attacking him from the inside represents
the very essence of all might himself
all might and his legacy created stars
and stripes so it is as if almighty
himself is now attacking all for one yet
again eventually the villain does manage
to use those wings to give the slip to
the jets and while this is unfortunate
for the pilots as far as they're
concerned stars and stripes has already
surpassed all might and she has already
become the greatest hero and her
ultimate sacrifice only underscores that
point but as the pilots mourn for their
fallen comrade all for one in chicago's
body is busy looking for someone anyone
to transfer new order to he somehow
manages to reach a coastal village that
is located in the boonies meaning away
from bigger cities and towns there he
comes across two people a guy and a girl
the guy is named kashi kakiko and he is
one of the many prison eskps who
regained their freedom thanks to all for
one's big prison break kashi had been
imprisoned for robbery and murder but it
is not clear whether he was imprisoned
in tartarus or in one of the other
prisons that all for one orchestrated
mass breakouts from if i remember
correctly i think there were seven
prisons in total anyway all for one
breaks into the house and grabs kashi by
the face all for one in shigaraki must
be undergoing tremendous pain and
suffering due to being repeatedly broken
down from the inside
but the villain refuses to give up his
plan is to steal kashi's own quirk first
and then transfer new order over to him
that way the villain will be able to
store new order inside of kashi until he
finds a way to make better use of it so
if all for one simply gave new order to
kashi without taking away his original
quirk then kashi would likely be dead by
the time all for one found a way to
actually use new order and of course if
kashi dies then new order would die with
him despite that deadly trap that stars
and stripes had set for him all for one
still wants to find a way to use new
order at some point in the future he
doesn't want to just get rid of the
quirk he wants to preserve it for later
but remember what i said in my previous
mha video i said that all of this
internal pain and struggle might awaken
tomorrow shigaraki aka tenko shimura and
prompt him to fight back against all for
one's domination over his body well that
very thing seems to have been
foreshadowed in this latest chapter as
all for one prepares to expel new order
from his body and transfer it to kashi
we see a panel showing little tanko
covered with a bunch of disembodied
hands these hands symbolize the control
that all for one is currently exercising
over tenko's body just as he had given
him those disembodied hands to cover his
body as part of his first villain
costume all those years ago those same
hands are now the symbol of tanko's
imprisonment inside his own body all for
one brainwashed tenko ever since he was
a child and he essentially groomed him
into becoming the perfect vessel and
what is tanko doing in the moment that
he is shown in this panel he thinks of
the concept of a hero and then he says
the words izuku midoriya whoa this panel
gave me goosebumps it was so creepy and
so symbolic but what exactly does this
panel mean is tenko maybe asking for
deku to save him is tenko simply
thinking about the fact that deku ended
up becoming everything that he had
dreamed of when he was a child or is
tenko thinking about deku for some other
reason either way this brief scene
proves that tomura aka tenko is still in
there somewhere and he is still
conscious to an extent that means that
he still has a chance to get his body
back from all for one but he will have
to fight for it the chapter then shifts
to a point where some time has passed
even though the army and the heroes
launched a massive search party for all
for one slash shigaraki they failed to
find him all they found was a damaged
house in a coastal village and to make
things worse the news that america's
number one hero died at the hands of a
villain quickly spread all over the
world and this absolutely terrified
everyone if this villain in japan is
strong enough to defeat even the world's
current strongest hero then who can
possibly stop him the other nations
immediately decide to keep all of their
heroes to themselves instead of sending
them to help japan because of course
they don't want to send their own heroes
to die at the hands of shigaraki and
then leave themselves vulnerable for
future attacks so it looks like japan is
now on its own even though some
international heroes like egyptian hero
salaam still want to help the japanese
heroes all in all things look really bad
at the moment stars and stripes is gone
new order is lost and the big boss got
away the other countries are scared and
japan will not be getting the
international backup that it had been
coping for however there is one silver
lining as one of america chan's brothers
explains the jets they flew on kept a
detailed record of the battle against
shigaraki that means they now have a lot
of valuable data about his biological
processes and the nature of many of his
quirks and this could prove to be
extremely important in the future this
is the one saving grace of this
otherwise tragic battle the next day
which is only two days after deku's
return to the ua grounds all might
explains to the class 1a students that
their mission to stop shigaraki has been
delayed shigaraki's body should have
been completed by the very next day but
because of the epic sacrifice that stars
and stripes has made the heroes were
given a week-long extension they now
have an extra week to plan and prepare
for their battle against shigaraki and
the villains and thanks to those pilots
they now have useful data that will help
them formulate the best possible plan of
action all might who deeply regrets that
he wasn't able to see stars and stripes
again but who also deeply respects her
service and her sacrifice tells the
students that they must use this extra
time wisely they have to commit to doing
everything they can to defeat all for
one and shigaraki and that is how this
chapter ends the absolutely epic battle
between shigaraki and stars and stripes
may have been a short one but it changed
everything in the story the very nature
of international relations in the world
of mha has been altered the fate of new
order is still unknown and that in
itself could be a game changer and the
heroes may have just gathered intel that
could prove to be crucial for defeating
the final villain things will not be the
same after this and there are still a
lot of unanswered questions that we need
to talk about first up what will happen
to new order now will this kashi guy
just serve as a quirk storage device for
all for one or is he going to learn how
to use new order and then try to escape
all for one's control let's face it he's
likely going to turn out to be an npc
because from what we've seen so far he's
just a criminal rather than a villain
but even so what will ultimately happen
to new order will someone else get it
will all for one try to disarm america
john's trap and use it for himself or
will new order be taken off the board
altogether if say kashi or whoever else
has it ends up dying with it definitely
let me know what you guys think about
the ultimate fate of new order down in
the comments below also what did you
think of young tenko calling out deku's
name how crazy is the similarity between
young tenko and young deku i mean take
away tenko's dry skin and scars and
change the hair color and eye color and
tenko could literally be mistaken for
deku tenko aka shigaraki truly is the
dark counterpart of deku if his life had
turned out just slightly differently
tenko might have become a hero like deku
but that one single night the night that
his quirk manifested changed everything
stars and stripes made the ultimate
sacrifice and entrusted her mission to
the future she entrusted it to the next
generation of heroes including of course
deku and not only is deku going to be
facing off against all for one and
tomorrow shigeraki but eventually he may
come face to face with tenko shimura and
let's be real tenko could end up being
deku's biggest weakness if shigaraki can
use the tenko persona to convince deku
that he can still be saved deku might be
tricked into lowering his guard and
that's when shigaraki might strike we
will have to wait and see because tenko
is still in there somewhere but how much
control does tenko have how much of this
is tomura and how much is all for one
it's really hard to say can deku somehow
get through to tenko before it's too
late don't forget to leave your thoughts
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this boku no hero video and you
want to see more you know what to do
just leave a quick like it helps a lot
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you watch our videos but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a quick favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications it might seem like a small
and insignificant thing but it's
actually a very important and totally
free way to support the channel you can
also hit me up on twitter and instagram
at animeopror i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime opera patrons
who make videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma this
man is an absolute mad lad and a
disciple of lord twego himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including ingrata algital
pate heffa the red-haired fox hinokami
and water the toasted chi corey mcgowan
the spike dylan isidor spidey life tinel
tungsten tarkis baked buddhist monkey d
quilly cody hebert and jeremy cummings
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers angel cruz very gucci
alicia octor bonnie parks joy and garcia
fat boy games kaido might be a duck
jessica rabbit and jeremy phillips if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value to you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these legendary people as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you